le F5 planteur
à la fin des années 1950 les grandes
plantations vivent leur dernier jour ces
vastes domaines sont peu à peu morcelés
pour être revendus à des colons l'une
des premières opérations de
redistribution des terres se déroule à
Saint-Benoît
la propriété valiaée et morcelée en
plusieurs lots attribue à des
agriculteurs venus des Avirons de
L'Étang-Salé de Saint-Pierre ou Saint
Joseph
encouragé par le Crédit Agricole cette
opération d'envergure donne naissance à
un village créé de toutes pièces
constituée de deux hameaux il est
baptisé Combourg abréviation de crédit
agricole mutuel bourg
il abrite à l'origine une cinquantaine
de maisons elles sont toutes conçues
selon le même plan type de l'architecte
Guy de jeûne qui les baptise F5
planteurs la symétrie de leur façade
rappelle les maisons traditionnelles
créoles
le béton coffret et les toitures
terrasses sont quant à eux
caractéristiques des années 50
dans les années 1970 kambour et doté
d'un réseau électrique et d'un système
de courant remplaçant les citernes
jusque la régulièrement remplie par la
vie
le village s'étend de nouveau F5
planteurs voient le jour
la distribution intérieure reste
identique une pièce centrale flanquée de
quatre chambres dont l'une généralement
convertie en cuisine
durant une décennie le F5 planteur se
diffuse en toute Lille tout comme la
castomie le fera à partir de 1961
ces deux maisons contribuent à la
naissance d'une nouvelle architecture
rurale